welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we've been watching The
Watchmen to break down everything that
you need to know about the new season on
HBO throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down one of the most
enigmatic characters in comic book
history that is dr. Manhattan the
godlike being that found himself at the
center above lady true and the seven
cavalries plants we're gonna be going
over the characters entire history his
powers abilities how he views time and
what we think may have happened to him
at the end of the season there will be
heavy spoilers here itself you won't
fully caught up with the show and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now to avoid
any confusion I'll be sticking with the
graphic novel timeline and the HBO show
that follows it but we may be covering
the Doomsday Clock timeline down the
line so keep an eye out for that
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of dr.
Manhattan Jon Osterman was born 1929 in
Germany the son of a watchmaker John
quickly learnt the skills of putting
timepieces together
and regularly he and his father went
through the inner workings of clocks
dismantling them and putting them back
together piece by piece in 1939 before
the outbreak of the Second World War
John and his family left Germany because
apparently his mother was Jewish
according to the graphic novel when
escaping the country they were stopped
at the border and during this John's
mother ran out from the wagon this
apparently distracted the soul just long
enough for his father to kill both of
them but John's mother was unfortunately
murdered in the process the show changes
this up slightly and says that John's
mother actually ran off with an SS
officer and she ended up abandoning them
it is possible that this is the truth
and out of shame John lied it's a story
about his father suddenly become a
murderer that it's capable of taking out
two soldiers well it seems a bit
far-fetched we don't have any concrete
answers for this but at least there is
enough here so you can draw your own
conclusions John and his father ended up
staying at Countryside castle that
became a safe haven for refugees and
those fleeing the war while sneaking
about John hid in a cover
and saw two people having sex they found
him and confronted the character about
it passing him a Bible and explaining
the story of Adam and Eve requesting
that he returned to the castle one day
after he's created something beautiful
these two would later go on to become
the Adam and Eve that John would create
on the moon of Europa after this stopped
off John and his dad moved to New York
where his father Joseph continued his
career as a watchmaker however after the
theory of relativity was created he
abandoned this profession John who was
supposed to follow in his footsteps was
then led down a course of studying
science where he studied between the
years of 1948 to 1958 John graduated
with the PhD in atomic physics and in
1958 he gained a job at a research base
at the Gila flats this position included
studying intrinsic fields which are
basically what holds matter together and
stops atoms from shifting and falling
apart John would later learn how to
manipulate intrinsic fields which is how
he's able to deconstruct and reconstruct
both himself and things around him
at the base he met Wally Weaver and
Janey Slater who he vividly remembers
bought him a beer Janey was the first
woman that ever did this for him and the
two began dating eventually going to the
Palisades amusement park in New Jersey
where they were photographed together
this photograph becomes one of the most
important images and dr. Manhattan's
life and throughout the graphic novel we
see him obsessing over it at several
points also when they were at the
amusement park Janie's watch strap
snapped and ended up falling to the
floor a passing man stood on it and John
picked it up bowing to fix it using his
skills as a watchmaker a month later
during the conducting of an intrinsic
field test
John accidentally left the watch in the
chamber and as he was going to give it
to Janey as a gift
he ended up rushing back for it
unfortunately becoming locked in the
chamber as the countdown to the launch
of the experiment begun unable to escape
John became trapped in the chamber and
his colleagues including Wally ended up
watching on as he was torn apart in
front of them
Janey couldn't bear to watch it and thus
she ran out of the room leaving John
calling out her name in what was really
a heartbreaking moment John was
disintegrated and seemingly killed in
the blast
and though a token funeral was held for
him and there was absolutely nothing to
bury the only thing that remained of him
was the photograph which was placed in a
memorial at the Keeler
that's however John was not dead and he
slowly began to reconstruct himself
similar to the watches that he used to
build at the Gila flats and nervous
system appeared and then later was
followed by a circulatory system not
long after a screaming skeleton
materialized on the grounds before John
did fully in the cafeteria on November
22nd 1959 the Superman is here he exists
and he's American John now thrust into
the limelight became a superhero working
for the American government under the
name dr. Manhattan which was meant to
strike fears and the enemies of the US
due to its closeness to the Manhattan
Project
he continued dating Janey Slater even
though he knew that you would break up
Gyan is an immortal standing still in
time whilst those around him move and
thus Janey grows old while she never
does forcing the two to slowly gain
distance between themselves under the
name of dr. Manhattan John acts as an
almost PR campaign for the US and ends
up dismantling Tanks publicly as a show
of strength for the country he even
visits the moon during the Apollo moon
landing and this begins to make other
countries in the world jealous of the
USA's newfound power john's
understanding of technology allows the
world to advance at a much faster rate
and because of this the watchmen world
is far more ahead than ours 'as the
advancements that he comes up with
actually tipped the Cold War in
America's favor and because of this the
rest of the world really began to
dislike the country it's at this point
that his relationship really comes under
strain and he and Janey argue and fight
a lot
John is then called upon by Captain
metropolis in the hopes of becoming a
member of a group known as the
crimebusters and at their first meeting
he comes across the second Silk Spectre
aka Laurie Jessa Peck the meeting pretty
much fails but the group are all put
into pairs with Laurie and Doc being
teamed up Janey says that doc made this
happen and that it wasn't done randomly
however John replies that they were
always meant to be paired together this
kind of leads into our next point which
is actually how dr. Manhattan fused time
so dr. Manhattan views all of the
moments within his lifetime at once he's
able to perceive each moment at the
exact same time and thus on the surface
he appears to have the ability to see
the future however all that he's doing
is looking at a moment in
BuChE and relaying it to a point in the
past in Watchmen attack Ian's devices
used by Ozymandias that limits his view
of the future and now he can't see
during its activation he can see around
it look it's very confusing
and I've tried explaining it multiple
times and yet it's very very difficult
John describes everyone including
himself as a puppet however he is able
to see the strings and because of this
he has some knowledge of being
controlled this is why he appears to
just go through the motions and why he
doesn't get out of the way of the 7th
Cavalry's cannon as that was always
meant to happen and therefore he needed
to be a part of it the way that I've
always looked at it is that the watchman
graphic-novel actually perfectly
demonstrates how the character views
time okay so if you read the graphic
novel you can see the events play out in
it you can read it from front to back
back to front choose any page at random
but the events the story it always plays
out the same John is basically a god
because in some ways he is us above the
story reading it able to control what
part of it plays out at that moment for
him and he has the ability to jump back
and forth through it depending on what
moment he wants to see
however he cannot affect it and this is
why he must continue doing certain
things John also has the ability to
teleport assemble and disassemble matter
levitate by shape-shift basically do
whatever he wants
or rather whatever this story wants him
to anyway that's a big tangent from his
bio
so when patrolling with Lori the to gain
an attraction for one another and he
ends up kissing her
Janey finds out and leaves him and not
long after his father Joseph dies he
reveals his true name to the world John
and Laurie moved to Washington together
and he's asked to intervene in the
Vietnam War which he ends not long after
in Vietnam he comes across the comedian
who kills a woman that he got pregnant
and John refuses to stop this from
happening
leading the comedian to say that he's
losing his grip on humanity whilst the
end of the war is great for the u.s. it
also raises fear in the rest of the
world which causes tension amongst the
population of the planet distrust for
vigilantes also begins to rise and riots
break out
costumed heroes mobs stormed the White
House but the doc teleports them all
home though to die from heart attacks
during this not long after senator Keene
passes the Keene Act which outlaws
masked heroes though doc continues
working for the government eventually
moving to Rockefeller military research
center where he lives with Laurie with
tension at boiling point and the fear of
a nuclear apocalypse right around the
corner Ozymandias create a plan to trick
the world into uniting itself and he
begins working on faking an alien attack
during this he infects Wally Weaver
Moloch a previous enemy of John and
Janey Slater with cancer
Ozzie too kills the comedian and
Rorschach goes to warn him that there's
a costume killer out on the loose but he
pays us no mind and transports him out
of the area focused heavily on his work
he allows Laurie to go out with dan
dreiberg and not long after he attends
the comedian's funeral later doc appears
on a chat show and during this he's
confronted by a journalist from the Nova
Express which is actually a magazine
that Ozymandias owns here he's accused
of causing cancer to people that have
gone close to him and in anger doc
teleports everyone out of the building
fed up with the planet he returns the
Gila flats and comes across the photo of
himself and Janey and then he teleports
to Mars
tensions rise once more and with the
u.s. no longer having its best defense
the rest of the world turns their arms
towards the country the threat of
nuclear war looms ever closer
eventually he returns to Earth to see
Laurie and together the two go to the
red planet where she convinces him to
help humanity John realizes that
Laurie's very existence is an improbable
miracle that had a billion to one chance
of ever coming true and this restores
his love for life he returns to earth
too late however an Aussie has already
launched his attack which wiped out
millions of people with Laurie he
travels to Antarctica to confront the
character but Ozzy has a contingency
plan in place and he disintegrates doc
using an intrinsic field weapon
Rorschach Laurie and night owl look
completely defeated
however doc has already put himself
together several times and he returns
once more going after the character just
as he's about to kill him
as he reveals that his plan to unite the
world worked and if the hoax is exposed
then everything will fall apart
Rorschach cannot abide by this and
dr. Manhattan is forced to kill him
after the character says that he won't
be silenced it's a brutal moment in all
adaptations and watching Rorschach
scream do it yeah that never gets old I
kind of butchered it there though with
Laurie now happy with Dan and humanity
saved dr. Manhattan decides to leave
Earth in order to create life somewhere
else cause he asked if his plan worked
and if he managed to end the war to
which doc replies nothing ever ends
from the show we learned that doc
actually traveled for the Jupiter moon
Europa in order to create life there he
rebuilds the castle from his childhood
and makes humans in the image of the two
that he met they're calling them mr.
Phillips and miss Cruikshank's whilst
living on the moon he sends a decoy to
Mars two robotic Li carry emotions that
made it look like he was on the planet
and thus he's able to hide his true
intentions however this place is too
perfect for him and he requires all of
the flaws that humanity have thus he
travels back to earth and in 2009 he
meets Angela a bar at a bar in Saigon
the two begin a ten-year relationship
with John taking on the appearance of a
dead man who doesn't have any family
members in order to raise no questions
John wishing to lead a normal life
decides to travel to Ozymandias for help
in exchange for a tachyon device that
will rid him of his memories doc
transports Oct roper where he can live
on the utopia that he was so desperate
to create before putting the device in
his head he goes to see will Reeves and
together the two form an alliance to
protect his and Angela's children in the
future together with Angela the to
travel to Tulsa and on an event known as
the white night in which the seven
cavalry attack police officers in their
homes he transports one of the attackers
to the Gila flats on pure muscle memory
this leads the seventh Cavalry to
discover that dr. Manhattan is hidden in
Tulsa and they begin to form a plan to
capture the character and steal his
powers thus allowing them to rule the
world
lady true made aware of the group I will
Reeves who used to be her to justice
instead wants to save the planet and she
too concocts a plan to steal the docs
powers and wipe out the cavalry in one
fell swoop after Angela Oberer doses and
Will's nostalgia pills in order to find
out the truth about him true saves her
and reveals the Cavalry's plan which
makes her a run home
unleash the doc from the unwitting cow
doc potentially puts his powers into an
egg and makes sure the Angela sees him
walking on water as a way to demonstrate
his godlike abilities I think this plays
into the ending which we'll get into in
just a bit
the cavalry captured Cal and go to
transfer his powers into Joe King jr.
but lady Tru transports them to the site
of the greenwood race massacre where she
is waiting with her millenium clock
which can take the docs energy and
transfer it the doc has sucked into the
machine and seemingly killed but
Ozymandias launches another squid attack
which destroys trues machine and her
powers angela returns home and finds the
egg eats it and then benches out onto
the pool which is when the season cuts
to black now personally I believe that
doc is alive and this is because he was
able to see the importance of the pool
and relay it from the future to Angela
the doc can only see within his own
lifetime and not beyond it thus in order
to know that this would be an important
place for Angela he would have to be
aware of it the doctors and joke about
and everything is absolute for the
character so the significance of the egg
in the pool definitely means something I
think Angela will gain his powers and be
able to restore him as his energy was
never absorbed by true and thus it's
still out there somewhere waiting to
return for season 2 also yeah he made a
duplicate on Mars so what why would the
one in the cage not be a duplicate he
seemed pretty bored anyway that's
another theory
now obviously I'd love to you your
thoughts on dr. Manhattan and if you
agree with my theories or not comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the finale in which we go
over the overall plot point out all the
Easter eggs you missed and give our
theories on the next season if you want
to come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which will be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free adjoining we have
an awesome community so hopefully I see
you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of 2019
and all you have to do to be and with a
chance of winning is like the video
which she subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on dr. Manhattan in
the comm
section below the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of January
and the set will be shipped out from
then to forget surprise so best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]